I have no debt on my name there were
some debt I cleared it out last year the
only thing we have is our mortgage which
currently is at
$350,000 I have a stable job I earn
around $150,000 from a job I have a wife
and two sons and I have $200,000 in a
savings account I cannot figure out if I
should invest in a real estate and then
create a passive income or are there
other better options that I should go
for I don't know if you like my answer
but if you filter this through the
Ramsey baby steps which people have
followed to become baby steps
millionaires you would be at what we
call Baby Steps four five and six so
invest 15% of your income we're saving
for the kids college and any extra money
we're going to throw at the mortgage
principal so we have found that one of
the keys to Building Wealth longterm is
to get a paid for house in the mix and
it's not one of the keys to Building
Wealth longterm is not keep A200 or
$350,000 mortgage while I go do real
estate that I learned on Tik Tok